quand on regarde le ciel la nuit
l'univers ne semble pas avoir de bord
l'univers a l'air de s'étendre jusqu'à
l'infini
et peut-être plus loin encore jordan ou
bruno adoré penser cela fini est une
chose que son dieu n'était pas et de nos
jours beaucoup partage ses réflexions
qui dans le passé avait défié la
religion mais certains trouvent
l'hypothèse d'un univers infini
embêtante et pour en savoir plus je vous
invite à aller voir ce super épisode de
sciences étonnante un tel univers aurait
une infinité de copies identiques de
nous-mêmes et moi c'était doucement mais
ça me pose problème
tout ça pour dire que je trouverais ça
très très très fort s'il était possible
de concevoir un univers finissant bord
ce fut du très très grand henri poincaré
quéven une réflexion de toute beauté
alors que beaucoup pensaient qu'un
univers finissant bord était un paradoxe
poincaré semi a longuement contempler
une horloge les aiguille avance
indéfiniment dans une seule et même
direction
pourtant l'horloge est un objet tout à
fait fini poincaré se rendit compte
qu'un objet assez banal méritait toute
son attention
cet objet n'est pas les aiguilles de
l'horloge mais la trajectoire que cette
aiguille décrit en termes mathématiques
sont dont on parlait du cercle et
surtout de sa topologie
il s'agit de la seule forme géométrique
de dimension un à la fois son bord est
fini mais le cercle n'ayant qu'une
dimension
se pose alors la question de sa
généralisation et bien notre terre est
une sphère dont on peut dire qu'elle n'a
aucune vraie frontière ou plutôt quelle
que soit la direction de votre chemin
vous pourrez marcher sans fin elle est
finalement plus surprenante qu'elle n'en
a l'air
notre belle planète terre mais la sphère
n'est pas la seule surface à avoir
autant de classe comme on l'a vu
quelques épisodes en arrière le monde de
pac-man à une propriété similaire le
monde de pac man est ce que l'on appelle
un tort et l'on a vu qu'il n'avait pas
de beurre
de façon équivalente le monde de pac man
peut être vu comme un carré
un carré dont on a collé les côtés
opposés de sorte que quand pac man sort
d'un côté
il réapparaît alors par le côté opposé
on a construit deux surfaces finissant
bord laisse faire et le tort mais voilà
qui pose d'une toute nouvelle sorte de
problème comment être sûr que ces deux
surfaces ne sont pas en fait les mêmes
comment peut-on certifier que l'on ne
pourra jamais des formes et continûment
une surface pour obtenir l'autre tout à
coup à la suite d'un tour de passe passe
pour distinguer différentes surfaces en
topologie poincaré inventa le mot topi
poincaré remarquer ainsi que les lacets
sur la sphère pouvait être secoué des
formes épurées réduit à néant
et puis surtout poincaré remarqua que
cela pouvait se faire en déformant les
lacets toujours continûment cette
remarque est valable pour la sphère
j'espère comme on est d'accord
en revanche cette même remarque n'est
pas valable pour le tort regardez par
exemple le lacet dessinée à l'écran vous
pouvez chercher à le déformer autant que
vous le voulez cela c'est traversera
toujours de gauche à droite le carré
vous ne pourrez donc pas faire
disparaître cela c'est continûment dit
du tort qu'il n'est pas simplement
connexes on en fait déjà vu un exemple
similaire à savoir la topologie du
cercle le lacet qui ont fait un tour
complet des formes et le autant que vous
le voulez jamais il disparaît après tout
tout des formations de cela c'est devra
faire en tour du cercle
et voilà comment on prouve que comme le
tort le cercle n'est pas simplement
connexes excellent a bien avancé dans
notre classification des surfaces mais
notre espace lui à trois dimensions
peut-on partir de la sphère et du tort
et construire des généralisations dont
la topologie s'applique à notre
véritable espace
on
c'est à la fin du 19e siècle que
poincaré généralise à tort ce faire et
cercles en fait un quart et découvrit
toute une collection de topologie
différentes que pouvait avoir un univers
finissant bord dans cette vidéo je ne
parlerais uniquement que de
généralisation de la sphère et du tort
je vais commencer par la généralisation
du second un espace à trois dimensions
le thor 3d est en gros un cube dont on
peut traverser les faces quant au sort
par la droite ont ré apparaît à gauche
quand on sort en haut on ré apparaît en
bas
et pour la direction avant hier il se
passe à peu près la même chose
comme vous l'aurez sans doute prédit le
thor 3d et sans bord est finie de plus
tout comme sa version 2d le cercle le
thor 3d n'est pas simplement connexes
mais qu'en est il maintenant de la
généralisation de la sphère bien on va
voir maintenant de quoi elle peut avoir
l'air
revenons-en d'abord à la sphère de des
quais la surface de la terre et on a
déjà vu que représentait cette sphère
c'est pas de la tarte le plus simple est
sans doute d'utiliser des cartes
ces cartes ne sont pas parfaites mais
elle nous seront nécessaires regardons
surtout de plus près cette carte centrée
sur le pôle nord surface entière de
notre terre il y est représenté par un
disque quoique il me faut tout de même
mettre un gros * sur cette carte
le pôle sud se trouve et est allée tout
le long du bord
bon j'espère que vous avez bien tout
ceci en tête et au fond de votre coeur
car on s'apprête à transposer ces propos
la dimension supérieure
par analogie et vous allez voir que ça
va être super cool une sphère 3d ou
trois sphères peut être représentée par
l'intérieur d'une blouse disons par
exemple par l'intérieur d'une pomme dont
les pépins sont une sorte de pôle nord
mais souvenez-vous la vraie trop ce
faire elle n'a pas de bord la peau de la
pomme représente en fait un seul et
unique hatton ou plutôt elle représente
un unique point de la transfère que l'on
pourra appeler le pôle sud
mieux encore les points proche de la
peau sont en fait juste à côté les uns
des autres
je pense que vous commencez à en avoir
l'habitude toute personne qui sort d'un
côté peut littéralement choisir
l'endroit sur la peau où elle va ré
émerger une dernière chose à dire sur la
trace faire enfin et que comme sa
version 2d
elle possède une connectivité simple
super on vient de décrire deux espaces 3
défini et sans bord à savoir le thor 3d
et l'a3 ce faire
mais qu'est ce qu'il peut y avoir
d'autres encore
telle est la grande question que
poincaré choisi de se poser mais il
sentait qu'il s'agissait d'une question
bien trop difficile
il opta donc pour une question plus
facile il réussit à la résoudre dans le
cas de la 2d il prouva que la sphère de
dimension 2 était la seule surface
finissant bord et simplement connexes
mais le cas de la sphère de dimension 3
le laisse un peu perplexe dans le
dernier supplément d'un noir qui allait
tout changer
poincaré écrivit que cette question
l'emmènerait trop loin
cette question est ce que l'on appelle
la conjecture de poincaré et pendant
plus d'un siècle de réponse il n'y en
eut point
ce n'est qu'en 2003 que le russe grigori
perelman résolu la question sa preuve
était très longue et très subtil et
vérifier sa validité flûte
incroyablement difficile après près de
sept ans ses pairs présentèrent enfin
leurs conclusions ils affirmèrent que la
preuve de perelman était correct seule
la 3 faire est un espace fini sans bord
et simplement connexes
pour sa preuve perelman reçu une flopée
de récompenses y compris un pactole d'un
million de dollars cette somme peut
paraître assez immense mais perelman
était disons un peu bizarre perelman
refuse à toutes ces décorations et
choisi de disparaître de la circulation
les à n'en pas douter les l'auteur d'un
exploit époustouflant non seulement at
il prouvé la fameuse conjecture de
poincaré
il a aussi profondément avancer notre
compréhension des espaces 3d
et puis enfin il a montré qu'il était
l'un des plus grands géomètre de tous
les temps cette vidéo sur les
connaisseurs de points car elle me
permet de mieux répondre à une question
de graff irb evp qui demandait où avait
lieu l'origine de l'ior surkov linux
avait très justement répondu en fait
tous points et l'origine de l'univers
pour mieux comprendre ça on peut prendre
une analogie en dimensions inférieures
va supposer que notre espace est une
sphère c'est-à-dire un cercle
or s'il me dit que l'univers est un
cercle c'est à dire que l'on est
vraiment collé au cercle on peut pas
rentrer à l'intérieur ou sortir du
cercle
on est vraiment collé le long de la
ligne qui est le cercle première
remarque que l'on peut faire c'est que
du coup aucun point du cercle n'est le
centre du cercle cercle en tant qu objet
de dimensions 1 sur lequel on vit n'a
pas de centre ce que nous dit la théorie
du big bang c'est que ce cercle
à l'origine il était tout petit puis
s'est mis à grossir on ne peut pas leur
en parler de la distance qui nous sépare
du cercle à l'origine puisque en fait on
était un des points 2
espace tel qu'il était à l'origine tout
cas j'espère que cette analogie en
dimensionnant vous permet de mieux
comprendre le commentaire de phoenix par
soi au lieu d'utiliser la neige et aux
dimensions utilise aussi analogie en
dimensions 2 qui correspond à dire que
l'espace où l'univers est une buse
certes dû faire quasi hier la surface
d'un ballon de baudruche typiquement et
la théorie du big bang nous dit ce
ballon de baudruche est en train d'être
soufflé que du coup les points s'éloigne
tous les uns des autres mais il n'y a
aucun qui n'est l'origine vont bien sûr
tout ça c'est en supposant que la
topologie de notre espace et bien eu
deux salles une sphère où je ne sais
quelle autre topologie dos desquels
gregg
j'en profite pour vous recommander cette
superbe vidéo 2000 physique ce tueur à
la théorie du big bang où il propose
justement lui de renommée de la théorie
du big bang et de la plaie le breuil
watch la théorie d'un espace qui s'étire
partout yahia l'info on a parlé des
trous noirs et tim bottes pose la
question de l'existence des troubles en
un troublant serait l'un vers un trou
noir c'est à dire qu'un trou noir tout
rentre dedans rien n'en sort un
troublant tout sort de ce troublant et
rien ne peut rentrer ma première
remarque à faire c'est que si vous êtes
à l'intérieur du trou noir
eh ben vous voyez leur est donné à
l'ex-star du trou noir comme un
troublant c'est à dire que le reste de
l'univers il ne peut que rentrer à
l'intérieur du trou noir et vous ne
pouvez pas sortir dans le reste de
l'univers du coup le reste de l'univers
est vraiment un trouble en tout cas sa
version d'avant la définition que je
vous ai donné lorsque dis moi tu avais
peut être en tête lorsqu'il parlait des
troublant c'est peut-être un troublant
qui ressemblerait un trou noir
c'est-à-dire un espèce de truc dans
l'espace temps comme ça et puis qui est
ou qui sort est-ce que ça ça peut
exister
d'un point de vue théorique tout ce que
l'on a à faire c'est juste un verset
l'axé ordonné hier traversé le temps si
on inverse le temps et on peut largement
faire ça puisque les équations de la
relativité générale d'einstein son
symétrique par rapport au temps il tient
un troublant la planète et ça ça me
permet aussi de réagir un commentaire
des rues 88 lui vata qui pose la
question est ce qu'on a vraiment le
droit de mélanger le temps à l'espace
est ce que ce n'est pas un peu ajouter
des pommes et des bananes notamment
sachant que le temps lui
unidirectionnelle il ne va que vers le
futur alors tout d'abord airs 88 l'uva
tard oui et un fuyard qui est assez
différent entre l'espace et le temps
d'un point de vue mathématique on parle
parfois de signatures plus - moins en
moins ou en plus plus en disant que le
signe du temps et l'opposé du cygne de
la surface la même façon on fait des
distinctions entre des séparations à
travers le temps et des séparations à
travers de l'espace qui a vraiment une
différence fondamentale entre l'espace
et le temps dans la théorie de l'espace
temps cependant la différence elle
réside sur la notion de causalité et ne
résident pas à temps sur le fait que le
temps est unidirectionnelle est en fait
la théorie de la relativité
d'un point de vue technique elle ne
contient pas vraiment la notion de
futurs ou de passer à nos vertes cas pas
la différence entre le futur et le passé
les concepts de futurs et de passer ne
sont que des choses que l'on rajoute à
la théorie pour l'interpréter parce que
ça ressemble à notre vie quotidienne et
du coût d'un point de vue strict aux
seins nus il n'y a pas de différence
entre un troublant et un de pouvoir la
différence n'apparaît que lorsqu'on
essaie de les interpréter avec une
direction du temps pour que l'on impose
un autre espace temps
enfin il ya la question la plus
difficile qui à là question de bart
toutatis qui nous pose la question
est-ce que lorsque l'on rentre dans un
trou noir au moment de traverser
l'horizon des événements on voit alors
défiler toute l'histoire de l'univers
devant nos yeux puisque s'apprête à
sauter dans un finir super lantin et là
il faut que je vous dise que en fait
j'étais un petit peu vite en besogne
dans l'épisode précédent qui faisait un
petit peu menti sur le fait que
l'intérêt du trou noir et le futur en
fait ce que je voulais vraiment dire
c'est que rien dans le trou noir ne peut
se trouver dans notre passé l'impression
que dire que rien n'est dans notre passé
et tout est dans le futur c'est
quasiment la même chose mais en fait en
théorie de la relativité il ya une
troisième possibilité on peut être soit
dans le passé de quelqu'un soit dans le
futur de quelqu'un soit déconnecté et
spatialement c'est ce qu'on avait vu
dans l'épisode sur l'expression 2015 qui
on peut avoir des séparations causal et
ça nous a permis notamment d'expliquer
pourquoi est-ce que sheldon peut ou ne
peut pas être emprisonnée dans une cage
sans qu'il y ait de paradoxe est en fait
quelqu'un qui rentre dans un trou noir
va être séparé spatialement de d'une
grosse partie de l'univers donc à la
fois l'univers ne pourra pas l'influencé
n'a pas observé univers mais lui ne
pourra pas donc leur force et une
lumière pour mieux comprendre ce qui se
passe on peut utiliser une carte de
l'espace temps où le temps passe vers le
haut et puis j'imagine qu'un tournoi
droite prend un observateur qui se
rapproche du trou noir
quand je dis que le temps se dilate un
truc que je sous entendais en disant sa
moyenne façon ou encore plus rigoureuse
de formuler ce que je chante redire mais
une façon de le dire c'est que lorsque
lui nous envoient des messages
la séparation temporel entre les deux
messages tels qu'on les reçoit va
grandir et ça ça vient du fait que le
cône de causalité se tourner quand
l'observateur se rapproche et du coup
les rayons de lumière sont de plus en
plus verticaux de sorte que le temps qui
passe entre deux signaux séparer d'une
seconde au moment de la réception va
être de plus en plus grands et c'est en
cela qu'on peut dire que la dilatation
du temps à ce moment là est infinie mais
les choses que lui pourront observer
sont des choses qui doivent appartenir à
son cône de causalité du passé et du
coup tout ce qui pourra observer
correspondra à un certain passé qui ne
contient pas toute l'histoire de
l'univers elle espère que j'avais aimé
cet épisode ça y est c'est le dernier
épisode de la série soit dans la dignité
général vous remercie de m'avoir
accompagné j'espère que vous continuerez
à vous suivre pour la prochaine série
dont le thème est encore à voter il ya
un google phone que je vous invite à les
compléter la clôture des votes les notes
rentrées juillet au soir minuit alors
qu'il restait deux épisodes en série le
premier c'est un épisode hardcore patron
soirée qui verra mais plus sur les
gobelets homophobie qui sont liées à
l'épisode d'aujourd'hui et il ya aussi
et surtout la délicate je vous rappelle
énoncé on jette une bouteille d'eau d'un
avion en vol que se passe-t-il
je vous invite à donner votre réponse
dans les commentaires du défilé 3
vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à la
ligue et à le commenter à le partager
vous pouvez me faire des dons surtout
vous souhaitez pensez à vous abonner
pour ne pas manquer des futurs épisodes
et j'espère que vous verrai pour la
prochaine série la classification de
toutes les surfaces fait intervenir la
somme connecter les trois surfaces de
base la sphère l'auto mort et le plan
projectif je prends la surface 20 ne le
sait pas encore
vous pouvez
vous pouvez me dit elle n'arriverait
jamais à la déformer en mots ce faire